estas posiciones de la artillería
ucraniana en especial aquí donde se
encuentran los Judith alemanes es un
ejemplo de las dificultades en esta
guerra especialmente en esta región del
Don báez donde la lucha se intensifica
no solamente en el frente de bacmut sino
en toda la línea de defensa ucraniana
pero a toda la ofensiva rusa se suma un
detalle especial y es el clima que hace
aún más difícil la movilización de todo
el ejército y toda la maquinaria
ucraniana en las últimas semanas han
empezado a subir las temperaturas ahora
el promedio es entre menos cuatro y
cuatro grados centígrados lo que ha
hecho que la nieve se derrita y en los
últimos días también ha llovido lo que
dificulta el transporte si ustedes ven
estos Campos son todos pantanales y
Estas son las dificultades no solamente
a la que se enfrentan esta maquinaria
pesada que está hecha para
circunstancias difíciles sino para todo
tipo de vehículos especialmente
ambulancias camionetas todo lo que lleva
y trae provisiones desde el frente pues
obviamente para las ambulancias evacuar
esos heridos Especialmente los soldados
es extremadamente difícil como también
poder llevar munición al frente y hay
otro elemento adicional muchos de la
artillería que utiliza son cañones que
llevan hasta puntos estratégicos Desde
allí disparan y tienen que salir
rápidamente lo que aún se hace aún más
complicado y nos cuentan los ucranianos
es que han tenido dificultades por
ejemplo para llegar hasta algunos puntos
algunos de esos carros o camiones se
quedan atrapados en medio de estas
planicies y muchas veces en medio de la
noche tiene que esperar a que las grúas
vengan a rescatarlos por muchísimas
horas bajo temperaturas ya en la noche
bastante difíciles Así que a las
dificultades de este frente del que se
encuentra en este momento se le añade
este elemento del clima que se espera
que continúe así por varias semanas aquí
en Ucrania ya ha entrado la primavera y
así que vendrán épocas de lluvia y donde
este barro seguirá siendo un impedimento
o un elemento más que haga más difícil
esta batalla